- [Narrator] You know,
stubbing your toe hurts.
It's right up there with
paper cuts and chapped lips,
annoying minor injuries that hurt way more
than they have any right to.
But it turns out there's a good reason
why stubbing your toe hurts so much.
When you stub your toe,
you're slamming it with a force
equal to two to three
times your body weight.
That's about the same
force as a karate punch.
And since your toe has
a tiny surface area,
that force can't be spread out,
so the pain stays concentrated
at the point of impact.
It's the same reason it hurts so much more
to step on the tiny,
pointy end of a thumbtack
than the wider, blunt end.
But you don't just feel
the immediate shock
like when you step on a thumbtack.
There's that aching
throb that comes after.
That's because when you stub your toe,
you're actually hitting a
bundle of special nerve endings
called nociceptors.
They all fire at once,
blaring a danger signal.
But some signals travel
faster than others.
The faster A-delta nociceptors
fire the first wave of signal,
which races at 20 meters per second
of thousands of densely
bundled nerve fibers,
and ultimately to your brain.
That causes the sharp,
sudden pain you feel
at the moment of impact.
But some nerve fibers
called C nociceceptors
send a slower signal at
only 2 meters per second.
So after a moment's delay,
the second wave of pain
signals reach your brain.
That's the dull throbbing that lingers on.
You can find nociceptors
all over your body
from your eyes to your bladder.
But they're concentrated
at the highest densities
in parts of your body that you use
to explore your environment,
like your fingertips and your lips.
That's why accidents like
paper cuts and chapped lips
can also hurt more than
they seem like they should.
Now, your toe isn't packed
with as many nociceptors
as your fingertips,
but since there's not
much in the way of padding
to cushion the blow,
it's easy to set those
unprotected nociceptors off.
And that's no coincidence.
Researchers suspect the pain
that we feel from mishaps
like a stubbed toe
might have even saved
our ancestors' lives.
Back before antibiotics,
even the tiniest cut could
mean a deadly infection,
and feet, which were constantly in contact
with dirty, bacteria-infested surfaces,
were particularly vulnerable.
So the people who had extra-sensitive feet
might have been more careful
about where they stepped.
As a result, they'd be less
likely to get infections
and would live to pass on their genes.
So the next time that
you collapse on the floor
cradling your aching toe,
you can thank your
great-great-great-great-great-great-
great-great-great-great-great-grandpa
for the privilege.